ma référence est historique il ya eu
déjà une épidémie de coronavirus en 1890
alors elle a été appelée malheureusement
la grippe russe ce qui fait que ça ne
facilite pas les choses pour retrouver
son origine mais il est un fait que
c'était très certainement une épidémie
de coronavirus c'est l épidémie du
coronavirus hausse et 43 c'est à dire en
fait monsieur linh à vos explique faysal
mieux que moi mais il ya quatre
coronavirus avec lesquelles nous vivons
de façon endémique je ne parle pas des
deux je parle pas du maire ce par
exemple qui est cantonnée à la péninsule
arabique ni du strass qui a disparu et
donc ces quatre coronavirus avec
lesquelles nous vivons en toute harmonie
depuis des décennies il a bien fallu
qu'ils arrivent à un moment on sait pour
trois d'entre eux qui sont arrivés il ya
très très longtemps à cause des de
l'horloge moléculaire vous savez on peut
remonter à l'origine de l'apparition des
virus de ronces et pour trois d'entre
eux qui sont arrivés à très longtemps
pour le quatrième le fameux os et 43 on
ne sait qu'il est arrivé en 1890 enfin
l'hiver 1889 1890
il ya eu à cette époque là il ya eu des
descriptions par des médecins qui ont
bien identifié que ce n'était pas la
grippe que c'était autre chose que la
grippe ils l'ont dit dès cette époque là
des médecins français notamment parisien
la première vague épidémique qui
arrivait en décembre 81 9 janvier 90
1889 1890 a fait environ 500 morts par
jour à paris
donc c'était un très bon modèle
historique je pense je regrette vraiment
beaucoup que c'est intéresser personne
et donc ce qu'on apprend sur 7 sur cette
épidémie de ses 43 c'est que il ya eu
plusieurs vagues épidémiques successives
les premières vagues épidémiques
rêver l'hiver comme l'été un dépôt donc
c'est pour ça j'ai toujours dit que
l'été évidemment levier russie
reculerait - pour des raisons
tout à fait logique mais que forcément
il y en aurait je me basais sur cette
épidémie de hausse et 43 et puis ensuite
les vagues sont devenus de plus en plus
espacées de moins en moins haute une
immunité collective c'est fait et
aujourd'hui on vit avec nos ses 43 qui
est parmi nous un j'en ai encore vu à 1
2 cas il ya un an qui était d'ailleurs
un cas particulièrement graves chez un
adulte d'une quarantaine d'années qui a
atterri en réanimation ce qui prouve que
les autres coronavirus peuvent aussi
envoyer en réanimation sauf que comme cd
coronavirus que nous rencontrons dans
l'enfance parce que ce sont des virus
qui circule très largement
à l'école au collège et au lycée quand
on arrive à l'âge adulte c'est moins
grave c'est un principe général en
maladies infectieuses
qui est de dire
que
les infections virales sont très souvent
en général moins graves chez l'enfant
que chez l'adulte c'est à dire il vaut
mieux les attraper chez l'enfant que
chez l'adulte c'est quelque chose qui
est très connue de nous infectiologues
historiquement nos maîtres nous l'ont
appris la varicelle par exemple on vous
prend un exemple il vaut mieux la
prendre la trappe et dans l'enfance que
la trappe l âge adulte a d'ailleurs à un
moment aux états unis à une vingtaine
d'années trentaine d'années les parents
organisent mmd varicelle parti pour que
leurs enfants soient contaminés pendant
l'enfance était beaucoup moins grave que
d'être contaminés à l'âge adulte il ya
la même chose il ya la même chose pour
la rougeole la rougeole c'est moins
grave c'est une maladie ravin de toute
façon même chez l'enfant mais c'est
quand même moins grave chez l'enfant que
chez l'adulte comment on s'en est rendu
compte à l'occasion de l'épidémie de
rougeole qui a eu lieu il ya quelques
années en france donc voilà il ya des
grands principes comme ça de maladies
infectieuses un autre principe
qui est générale c'est que en général
quand un virus mute pluie stransky
gagnant transmissibilité il le perd en
pathogénicité et donc c'est un peu ce
qu'on est en train d'observer avec le
leur mikron c'est à dire que le home
itron est beaucoup plus transmissible
beaucoup moins pathogène enfin moins
pathogène en tout cas et d'ailleurs on
voit toute limite toute la population
française est en train de s'immuniser
avec l'eau mikron malgré des vaccins etc
donc voilà je mets deux boussole pour
être clair 440 va maintenant être
enregistrés
non mais je suis pas inquiet du tout
donc voila mais de boussole c'est
l'histoire des maladies infectieuses et
c'est les connaissances que j'ai
acquises en tant qu infectiologues parce
que je suis pas un infectiologue
uniquement
orienté sur une maladie particulière
comme par exemple l'infection vih ou
même le que ville aujourd'hui j'ai un
infectiologue et une vision que je
revendique comme étant très large de ma
spécialité
c'est voilà c'est comme ça que j'en suis
arrivé
à dire ça donc principalement
connaissance historique de l'épidémie de
grippe russe dit grippe russe de 1889
1890 qui a duré trois à cinq ans et
c'est pour ça qu'au début j'ai dit que
cette épidémie du ray 3 500 gens me
disaient qu'elle est sombre source mam
les sources étaient l'histoire voilà
tout simplement je pense que sa valeur
en s'atténuant de plus en plus on aura
évidemment des resucées
je pense hivernale notamment mais ça va
finir par s'installer parmi nous comme
les autres comme les quatre autres
coronavirus voilà après on peut toujours
faire des scénarios catastrophe mais je
ne verse pas dans ce catastrophisme la
même si je dois reconnaître que la
vérité c'est qu'on en sait strictement
rien évidemment on peut élaborer un
seigneur un scénario rassurant comme on
peut élaborer un scénario catastrophe
mais l'histoire des épidémies d'histoire
des maladies infectieuses nous enseigne
ce que je vis ions optimiste des choses
pour le moyen terme et le long terme
[Musique]